The modern workday is no longer a sensible, reasonably paced 9 to 5.
Today, business is a twenty-four seven blitz, stacked end-to-end...
...with win-wins, net-nets, synergy and low-hanging fruit.
But what effect does all this have on a businessperson's most important tool:...
...their brain?
Is it even possible for it to remain focused on what should matter most:...
...your real business?
Introducing Business of Your Brain,...
...brought to you by Xerox.
It's one of many ways we're helping you to get ready for real business,...
...and is a breakthrough in unproven completely unscientific mental activity analysis.
What does it do?
Business of Your Brain probes the depths of your cerebral cortex,...
...well, technically your Microsoft Outlook, which is kind of like a cerebral cortex,...
...to analyze your brain's workday activities, confidentially, of course,...
...and detect potential obstacles to your ability to focus on real business,...
...obstacles such as e-mails long enough to be published in hardcover,...
...11 PM brainstorming sessions, overuse of mind-numbing cliches...
...like "action item" or "push the envelope",...
...and that guy in procurement who sends you 50 e-mails a day just to say thanks.
Business of Your Brain...
...is just one way Xerox is trying to help you focus on what's really important:...
...your real business.
Xerox's Business of Your Brain.
Be the office genius.
Tell your friends and coworkers to download it free today.